[Musique]
bonjour mesdames jeu des interprètes en
langue des signes sur le relais
téléphoniques rogers boys une personne
sourde ne cherche à vous contacter je
vais vous mettre en relation je vais
traduire votre communication d'accor
c'est un monsieur qui vous parle et qui
vous dit bonjour je suis monsieur dumas
j'ai réservé il ya quelques temps bien
le bon coin un appartement la montagne
et j'aurai quelques questions
complémentaires vous posez voilà je
voudrais savoir si je peux garé ma
voiture à côté de l'appartement et dans
quelles conditions
aba dans ce cas là je prendrai bien la
place en parking c'est possible adacore
très bien etc etc je viens de vous
montrer mon quotidien je suis interprète
en langue des signes français langue des
signes française je suis interprète
depuis 13 ans mais je suis vision
interprète depuis deux ans c'est pas un
métier qu'on choisi par hasard
comment je suis arrivé là en fait au
départ grandes écoles de commerce
diplômé de l'estp j'ai fait une carrière
dans la finance tout ce qu'il ya de plus
classique du conseil du contrôle de
gestion
une direction financière dans des
grosses multinationales les équipes à
l'international des responsabilités
enfin bref la vie de la femme business
women classic pendant 18 ans quand même
avec petit tailleur des petits trucs
tout ça dans les avions dans les
réunions bref 18 ans et puis un jour une
rencontre choc un petit sourds très très
très très mignon mais bull dans ma vie
je vous raconterai pas de l'état c'est
ma vie privée et
et à cause de lui ou grâce à lui je sais
pas je j'ai eu envie d'apprendre la
langue des signes
dès le premier cours ça a été un coup de
foudre intégral pour cette langue et
pour l'univers qu'elle ouvrait des gens
une culture une histoire une façon de
voir le monde
quand on ne l'entend pas j'ai été
subjuguée ça m'a pris aux tripes et du
coup j'ai tout planté là j'ai repris mes
études je suis rentré en master 2
d'interprétation français langue des
signes française et je suis devenu
interprète en langue des signes
alors évidemment quand j'ai fait ce
changement professionnel tellement
drastiques
mes amis ma famille se sont offusqués
entendu ça va pas la tête tu abandonné
une carrière en finance qui était super
bien partie très prestigieuse
tout ça pour faire quoi pour aller dans
des banlieues souvent improbables
traduire des cours de comptes à des
cours de mécanique des cours de cariste
des rendez vous à l'hôpital les rendez
vous chez le notaire des rendez-vous à
cap emploi des formations en tous genres
et des réunions d'informaticiens tout ça
pour pour des sourds et bibis pourquoi
parce qu'en fait alors moi aussi je me
suis posé des questions au moment de
juger bien ça effectivement pourquoi
j'ai fait ce virage comme ça hein si
important et je me suis interrogé et je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fait déjà
quand j'étais à le s&p donc jeune fille
j'avais choisi ses études un peu par
hasard mais la seule chose qui
m'intéresse est vraiment dans la vie
c'était parler des langues étrangères
parce que je trouve que c'est très doux
au cerveau la manipulation de langues
étrangères
voyager de par le monde faire le tour de
la planète rencontrer
des gens différents des cultures
différentes rencontres et les autres
écouter leurs histoires ça ça me
plaisait beaucoup
alors c'est vrai que maintenant et puis
j'avais aussi envie quelque part d'avoir
un job qui a du sens et donc c'est vrai
que maintenant avec la langue des signes
et l'interprétation pour les personnes
sourdes
l'objectif est complètement atteindre
mon quotidien en fait c'est une espèce
de voyage permanent dans un pays inconnu
le pays des sourds il est tout autour de
nous il est dans la société on ne voit
pas les personnes sourdes on ne les voit
pas non plus elles sont complètement
invisible et j'ai dans mes mains une
langue complètement génial magnifique
sublime avec laquelle je vis tous les
jours donc en gros je me lève le matin
je prends le métro je suis dans le monde
normal et puis après je rentre dans ma
quatrième dimension à passer ma journée
de travail
dans ce monde où chaque langue porte sa
culture
ces individus son histoire et c'est vrai
que les personnes sourdes que je
rencontre depuis maintenant une
vingtaine d'années sont extrêmement
riches à découvrir parce qu'en fait
elles n'entendent pas elle découvre le
monde par leurs yeux en général et puis
par d'autres moyens si par exemple des
très grands décrypteur de non verbale
c'est les personnes qui vivent dans une
grande adversité parce que la société
n'est pas très favorable à l'accueil de
la différence et du handicap etc des
personnes qui sont très très riche à à
découvrir donc mon quotidien moi c'est
ça c'est ces espèces de voyages
quotidiens dans un pays différent mais
c'est aussi cet engagement professionnel
que j'ai pris maintenant depuis
plusieurs années transforme le quotidien
d'autres personnes de centaines d'autres
personnes
et à ce titre après avoir fait très
années l'interprétation langue des
signes sur le terrain me déplacer là où
les sourds avait besoin qu'on leur rende
la vie accessible depuis deux ans j'ai
rejoint une petite start up qui
s'appelle rogers boys qui a été créé par
un entrepreneur qui est lui même sourd
et dont la mission est de rendre le
téléphone accessible aux sourds et
malentendants et ça c'est une mission
extrêmement excitante et très belle
alors le parmi les personnes sourdes et
malentendantes on estime qu'il ya 6
millions de sourds et malentendants en
france pour la grande majorité ces des
personnes comme vous et moi qui en
vieillissant père de l'audition et sur
ses 6 millions de malentendants
il y en a à peu près 500 milles qu'ils
entendent rien du tout même avec des
appareils auditifs et sur ces 500 milles
on estime que ceux qui pratiquent la
langue des signes ils sont assez peu
nombreux ils sont pas très bien relancé
mon estime qu'ils sont entre soixante
cinq mille et 120 milles donc le
téléphone et rendu accessible comment
pour les personnes qui en entendent
vraiment rien avec des appareils pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas la langue
des signes est bien les propos de leurs
interlocuteurs sont retranscrits en
direct sur leur smartphone c'est comme
si j'avais un sous titrage instantané de
la réponse de leurs interlocuteurs
entendants et pour la partie qui me
concerne
via la webcam d'un smartphone parce que
rogers boss est une application qu'on
télécharge très facilement sur les
stores le la personne sont thomas en
contact avec un interprète qui lui
ensuite se met en contact avec une
personne entendante eva il va traduire
la communication comme ce que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure les interprètes de
l'équipe sont tous diplômés d'un master
2 et traduisent les conversations dans
une déontologie extrêmement strictes
l'interpréter totalement neutre donc il
ne donnera jamais son avis dans une
conversation
l'interprète est totalement fidèle c'est
à dire qu'on traduit tout même quand les
gens s'insultent s'envoient des noms
d'oiseaux ou se disent des petits mots
d'amour ce qui n'est pas toujours très
facile à traduire et l'interprète suit 1
secret professionnel extrêmement fort
c'est à dire pour que les personnes
sourdes et confiance dans notre travail
on est obligé de leur garantir que
toutes les conversations qu'on va
traduire sont absolument
secrète et confidentielles alors le
téléphone existe pour les entendants
depuis bien année beaucoup d'années
c'est pour nous ç'a toujours été un
outil de la vie de tous les jours pour
les personnes sourdes de téléphone
n'existe que depuis deux ans c'est vrai
que quand on a lancé le relais
téléphonique au départ
les souris est un peu timide il savait
qu'ils avaient le téléphone n'y avait
pas trop comment l'utiliser donc au
début il passait des appels très courts
et par exemple on a dû beaucoup les
accompagner pour leur expliquer ce que
c'était qu'une sonnerie de téléphone que
quand le téléphone sonne et ben ils
n'étaient pas nécessairement toujours
décrocher et ils demanderaient pourquoi
ça décroche pas mais parce que ces
personnes soient plus difficiles que
parfois quand on téléphone et des
musiques d'attentes donc ils
s'impatientent et hanzal et aurait pour
moi je jouis bilaï il ya un disque il ya
un robot bas ne peut pas traduire et
puis petit à petit ils se sont approprié
le téléphone mais d'une façon assez
fulgurante est maintenant l'heure ils
appellent pour tous pour pour tous pour
tous n'importe quoi réservations chez le
garagiste coiffeurs esthéticiennes
tatoueur vétérinaire pour leurs animaux
ils organisent leur mariage ils
commandent les gâteaux d'anniversaire
ils font appel un jardinier pour
construire leur maison ils discutent
avec leur maçon il pose des questions
sur comment changer une roue ils
prennent rendez vous chez le notaire
enfin ils appellent pour tous et à tel
point qu'on se demande
bah oui mais comment il faisait avant vu
qu'on est débordé d'appels toute la
journée et ben en fait on s'est rendu
compte qu avant il ne faisait pas il
était au centre auto censuré dans leur
vie par manque d'accessibilité ou alors
il est obligé de faire appel à quelqu'un
de leur famille pour leurs démarches
administratives
le quelqu'un en question prenait en
général toutes les décisions à leur
place et donc là on se rendre compte
qu'en fait en donnant le téléphone
accessible aux personnes sourdes
on leur donne de l'autonomie et on les
rend citoyens et acteurs de leur propre
vie et ça c'est une fierté énorme
et puis par ailleurs
[Musique]
en regardant fonctionner ce relais
téléphonique moi je me suis rendu compte
que maintenant que les sourds peuvent
téléphoner à n'importe qui ils peuvent
téléphoner à leur coiffeur ils peuvent
téléphoner à leurs voisins ils peuvent
téléphoner aux membres de leur famille
qui avec lesquels il avait jamais parlé
parce qu'ils partageaient pas la même
langue
ils peuvent appeler vous vous demain et
bien toutes ces personnes entendantes
qui dans leur vie de tous les jours ne
rencontrerait jamais un sourd tout d'un
coup elle se trouve en communication
avec un sourd alors il ya un petit
moment c'est quoi il ya un sourd qui
m'appelle l'église est qu interprète
c'est trop bizarre on les rassure en
inquiétez pas ça va bien se passer
et puis ya une communication qui se met
en place et finalement les personnes
entendantes se disent ah bah tiens le
sourire à 7 personnes sur 10 peuvent
louer un appartement à la montagne il
peut me demander une place de parking
il peut prendre rendez vous pour se
faire couper les cheveux ils peuvent
emmener son chien à vacciner et
finalement ça crée un espèce de lien et
ça ça ça sensibilise en fait tout le
monde
ah au fait que d'être sur ses pas si
catastrophique que ça que les sourds
sont des gens normaux qui vivent comme
nous ils se marient ils ont des enfants
ils passent le permis de conduire il
travaille et ça permet déjà de
d'éliminer pas mal d énormes préjugés
qu'on a sur les personnes sur les
personnes sourdes et ça aussi c'est un
effet secondaire auxquels on s'attendait
pas et qui est vachement vachement
chouette j'ai oublié de dire qu'en fait
chez rogers j'encadre l'équipe des
interprètes en langue des signes donc
maintenant à peu près 60 personnes et
comme c'est une start up qui est tout
petit et que j'ai quelques compétences
en finance j'assure aussi la direction
financière
voilà donc qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de
qu'est-ce que je n'avais envie de vous
dire on en vouloir ce soir pour vous
parler de cette expérience
la première c'est que il faut pas avoir
peur de la différence
alors ça c'est vrai c'est une phrase
super convenu que tous les drh ans à la
bouche mais en fait la phrase il faut ce
qui est important c'est qu'il faut pas
seulement là dit il faut la mettre en
application
et ça ça demande un petit peu de courage
ça demande un petit peu d'originalité
la deuxième chose je voulais vous parler
des sourds pour vous dire que
effectivement quand on fait de la langue
des signes les gens sont fascinés on
verra c'est beau c'est assez incroyable
mais c'est pas une lampe pour faire joli
c'est une langue dont un certain nombre
de personnes ce qui sont certes pas très
nombreux en france mais c'est une langue
dont les gens ont besoin et donc la
langue des signes c'est pas pour se
faire plaisir à soi c'est pour
communiquer avec des gens qui en ont
besoin et il faut quand même savoir
qu'en france comme dans pas mal de pays
occidentaux
la société souffre d'un mal a dit que
on appelle l'autisme c'est à dire là qui
se signe comme ça en langue des signes
c'est à dire concentration sur l'oreille
quand on a affaire un sourd qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut qu'il entendait on
veut qu'ils parlent et en fait les
enfants qui naissent ou rim a quand même
un pour mille en france quand ils sont
petits cette langue des signes ont la
leur donne pas on la leur propose pas
tout ce qu'on leur propose ses des
appareils auditifs et des cours
d'orthophonie pour en fait rentrer dans
une norme qui est limite inatteignable
pour eux et donc si on commençait à se
décrisper un peu par rapport à cette
volonté absolue de faire parler et
entendre les personnes sondées si on se
reconcentre est un petit peu sur la
langue qui leur est facile et facile
parce qu'il la voit et qu'ils ont
beaucoup de compétences visuel on les
aiderait beaucoup à grandir parce que
effectivement canton
on doit être dans un apprentissage sans
maîtriser la langue parce qu'on l'entend
pas l'école est compliquée les études
supérieures sont quasi impossibles
trouve un boulot c'est super dur et
s'insérer dans la vie
voilà ça relève du parcours du
combattant
donc cette langue des signes qui est si
belle admirez la mais aussi pourquoi pas
puisque vous êtes jeunes avec des
cerveaux plastique
apprenez là et quand la langue des
signes sera mieux diffuser dans la
société on aura tous collectivement
beaucoup moins peur des personnes sont
et puis après ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire aussi c'est que quand on a la
chance d'être né au bon endroit au bon
moment
sur des rails c'est sympa qu'on se
retrouve dans une école de commerce ou
dans une école d'ingénieurs assez
favoriser qu'on a du talent de la chance
eh bien peut-être pour donner du sens à
sa vie ou à son travail c'est totalement
et cette chance peut-être ne pas les
garder que pour soi et on en profite et
que pour soi même mais les partager avec
d'autres qui n'ont pas autant de talent
autant de chances qu'ils sont pas
forcément nés dans les meilleures
conditions
et ça je crois que quand on cherche un
boulot quand on construit sa carrière
en tout cas ça a marché pour moi ça
donne beaucoup de sens à ce qu'on fait
et enfin mais ça a été dit avant si vous
êtes sur des rails bien tracé bien
huilée n'oubliez pas de regarder un côté
les petites fleurs qui poussent au bord
du chemin
peut-être pensé à prendre les chemins de
traverse pensez à aller voir ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur ça peut faire peur
c'est parfois une prise de risques mais
ça donne aussi beaucoup beaucoup de goût
à la vie et puis bon comme vous êtes
jeunes moi je vous dis attention à vos
oreilles protéger les
[Applaudissements]